hey youtubers is Charlie so hopefully
you've all had a chance to see The
Walking Dead by premiere they've been
posting a lot of clips since comic-con
but I was still so blown away with the
episode I'm also restarting the weekly
Walking Dead giveaway right now it's
just a weekly Amazon giftcard given to a
random subscriber in the comments all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video since there is so much that we
need to talk about this is gonna be a
top 10 video that I'll do my review and
then I'll talk about the rest of the
season
so careful for spoilers from the episode
if you haven't seen it yet which is sick
okay ready here we go number 10
terminus origin story this was a
flashback to explain how the terminus
people got to be the way they are how
they turned into cannibals they cut it
up across the episode and Mary was the
one that narrated the action to Carol
but basically a group of thugs came in
and just tore the hell out of him I feel
like there's gonna be a lot of debate
about this but I feel like it's possible
that that's an Easter Egg for negan and
the Savior's from the comics if you have
read the comics just please use spoiler
tags when you're commenting about those
people Kirkman and Gimple have said
multiple times that they're not gonna do
that character yet but that doesn't mean
that they're gonna squeeze him in in a
cameo just the same way they squeeze
Morgan and at the end
Campbell actually said something funny
on talking dead he said that the people
there just got so detached from the
awful things they were doing that it
turned into an episode of The Office on
NBC like a mundane workplace sitcom it'd
be like if Jim pranked Dwight by killing
someone he loved and putting him on his
desk number 9
welcome to the kill floor I think this
was Robin Lord Taylor here the guy that
Rick gave his watched to in season 4 his
name was Sam Carroll did find Rick's
watch later so even if it wasn't Sam he
still came through terminus at some
point and then came through the
intestinal tracts of the people there
just a little bit of cannibal humor if
you've never been on a kill floor before
where they carve up cows and pigs they
bleed them out first and troughs like
this and then they cut them up
I feel like Glen with the baseball bat
does another negan Easter Egg also
please use spoiler tags when you're
commenting about it slugger here almost
gets him twice with the bat I feel like
that's one too many times to be a
coincidence it might just be Scott
Gimple messing with our heads because he
was one of the writers in the episode
number 8 Carol and Tyreese joined the
party I feel like them on the outskirts
with
terminus guy was more of a Tyrese
situation than a Carol thing she kind of
went off and did her own thing it's all
about differentiating the terminus
people as being bad and the survivors as
being good even though they kind of do a
lot of the same things like they both
kill people they're both very violent
groups a season five is all about how
they're gonna be much more of a family
than they've ever been before
like a real family Abraham Eugene and
Rosita are still kind of Outsiders it
seems like they don't trust them enough
to explain the Washington DC stuff but
that's like a whole other story line I
was really proud of Tyreese though we
know exactly how Carol's gonna react in
any given situation you know she's the
tiger mom of the group Tyreese was the
one hopping on one foot try not to crush
that guy's skull even though they didn't
show it I feel like it was like an
Oberyn Martell vs. the mountain thing on
Game of Thrones I mean the minute
someone threatens baby Judith's life you
know that they automatically have to die
there is no way they're making it to the
next episode number seven Carol blows
the gas tanks Carol was definitely the
MVP of the episode and this was the best
practical effect probably the most
expensive one - I love that she went
straight into Rambo mode no hesitation
walker camo and all the minute she knew
something was up she just went into Auto
Search & Destroy mode there was this
weird thing going on during the
comic-con panel this past weekend
Melissa McBride was crying so everyone
thought that meant that she might be
dying I have seen some pictures of them
filming episodes this season at least
from the first half of the season and I
can say that she's in episodes I don't
know when she's actually gonna die or if
she is but it is totally possible just
in general though
do not worry about Carol like she's
gonna be fine for at least a little
while number six Machine Gun Rick from
the minute he stabbed those two guards
it was just a marathon of gore till he
got his hands on that machine gun and
even after they escaped he was gonna go
back and stomp out the rest I wonder how
much longer he would have argued with
him if carol hadn't walked up I don't
think he's crazy this season I mean he
still listens to reason but I think a
lot of his sanity depends on Carl and
Judith
so hopefully nothing happens to them
during the whole Rick montage did anyone
else have a flashback to season 3 when
they were clearing the prison that was
like video game levels of violence where
he had unlimited ammo and unlimited
lives like he was just walking through
the prison just hacking people
that was also the same episode where
they hacked Herschel's leg off to number
5 eugene and the cure I laughed so hard
when Sasha questioned Eugene and just
gibberish poured out of his mouth he's
like one of those guys who thinks if he
talks fast enough and confuses people
don't forget what's going on and it
totally worked they totally bought it
eventually I do think that's gonna be
over like they'll have to figure out
what his secret is and if you have read
the comics just please use spoiler tags
when you're talking about the cure Sasha
seems like she's gonna be the one
pushing Eugene this season though for
answers or at least Abraham's group in
general number four Harold versus Mary
this was the explainer for those
flashback scenes Scott Gimple said that
they wanted to tell the story of how
terminus got to be the place we're
seeing right now they weren't always
cannibals they just got pushed too far
and snapped it's a wicked way for Tosh
er to go but I always loved seeing her
pop up on big shows she got kills on an
episode of Dexter during season 1 I
think to where she got murdered by
Dexter maybe it's just that Denise
Crosby really likes dark stories but I
was happy they expanded her part like
she was just barely a part of the finale
last year and I love that they let it
all go down in that creepy candle room
if you ever wanted to make your own
haunted house all you'd have to do is
just make it creepy candle room just
like that that would totally do the
trick
number 3 the reunion this was the cry
worthy moment everyone is reunited or at
least the ones that are still alive
I get the sense that Rick is gonna try
and permanently attach baby Judith to
his body they've been separated
ever since the prison battle so this was
a big payoff Tyreese and Sasha - I feel
like she's gonna help keep him under
control or keep him saying did anyone
else to look at Daryl here and feel like
he looked kind of sad watching them
during the reunion I feel like he was
thinking about Merle like he's part of
the family I think he feels like part of
the family but he's still really sad
about what happened to his brother
the interesting thing during that
reunion is that Abraham's group was kind
of off on the side
number two negan and the Savior's it was
really the second flashback that gave me
the strong negan vibes I don't know if
they're gonna do any more cameos with
these mystery attackers this year but
the slicked back hair the voice and the
leather jacket just screamed negan to me
you guys can let me know if you agree
but I feel like they can do this as a
small cameo without bringing
the show and like that wouldn't be
violating all the stuff they've been
saying really though the number one WTF
moment Morgan is back
I think this scene only lasted a couple
seconds but it totally did the trick
everyone just dropped right out of their
chairs somebody actually asks Robert
Kirkman about this at Comic Con a couple
days ago he said that Morgan was
definitely coming back on the show
but it's dependent on the actors
schedule I think he was talking about
coming back on as a series regular so
that makes me wonder if this is just
gonna be a one-time cameo let me know
though what was your favorite moment
from the episode and when do you think
that Morgan's going to come back just a
heads up to on some of the other
characters based on the teaser for the
next episode Seth Gilliam will be
introduced he's playing father Gabriel
from the comics I already did a video
explaining his character so I'll add a
link in the description if you want to
learn more Andrew J West - the guy who
plays Gareth he was promoted to series
regular so he's not dead he will be back
overall though I just gave the episode a
solid a four making a roaring come back
to television Walking Dead is the most
popular show on cable right now so it's
almost ridiculous to expect it to keep
one-upping itself every week that being
said they usually crank all the knobs on
the stories and the tension up to 11 for
premieres and finales so it's to be
expected that this would be extra crazy
they answered a ton of questions about
all the characters did a good job of
explaining what the new dynamics of the
group are gonna be and resolved a lot of
a hangover plot from season four the
real question mark is what's going on
with Beth hopefully we'll see her at
some point in the second episode I would
have also liked to spend a little bit
more time in the terminus flashbacks but
we might get more of those whenever
Gareth shows up again all the things
that the Rick is gonna be a lot more fun
this year I'm really looking forward to
that more than anything else
Carol is really the MVP though like she
is my MVP of this episode let me know if
you agree though is Carol the biggest
badass right now so in related news I
will be doing a Q&A for this tomorrow so
be sure to leave all your questions also
announce the winner of the giveaway
again all you have to do to enter that
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video it's just an Amazon gift
card really simple right now click here
to get that video and click here for my
top 5 Rick rhymes moments thank you so
much for watching so let's all high-five
I'll see you guys tomorrow
you